groomed from the age of 12 by older
mainly asian men jane not her real name
suffered six years of horrific sexual
and mental abuse
i were powered with drugs alcohol and
raped over and over again social knew
this police knew this
i think everyone knew
the arthritis
they all knew
we just turned a blind eye
jane lived in oldham she says the abuse
took place in different locations
she shows takeaways
houses
just loads of different places
just yeah everywhere
a review looking at child sexual
exploitation in oldham was commissioned
in 2019 after reports of grooming
including abuse at shisha bars published
today the review found there were some
concerning incidents involving young
teenagers at these bars although it says
most had closed by 2013.
it also detailed more widely how the
authorities have failed to protect some
children the police and oldham council
have apologized it is clear that at the
time the council and the police did not
understand enough about this horrendous
crime and how best to support and
protect its victims
much has changed since then we've learnt
from similar reports and reviews
elsewhere in the country from changes to
national guidance and from best practice
and the way we deal with victims of the
terrible abuse is now completely
different while there was no evidence of
widespread grooming there are shocking
revelations like what happened to sam
who sky news has previously spoken to
back in 2006 at just 12 years old sam
was sexually assaulted and raped by
multiple men in one day
the review found both the council and
police appeared to cover up their
failings to protect her and says the
police didn't investigate some potential
suspects on too many occasions
we the police were not there for you
when you desperately needed us
and for that
i am truly sorry the lessons of this
report have already
been
learned and are well baked in
to our current professional practice
greater manchester police have set up a
new operation to investigate the
findings of the review survivors hope
this could finally bring them justice
becky kochel sky news manchester